the medical examiner covering
Minneapolis is now ruling that George
Floyd's death was a homicide
now this comes after an independent
autopsy requested by Floyd's family and
it showed that he died from a lack of
oxygen due to sustained pressure on his
back and his neck former police officer
Derek Chauvin is currently charged with
third degree murder which means that he
is accused of killing Floyd
unintentionally Jeff Pegasus in
Minneapolis Jeff where does this
investigation stand now well it is
ongoing as far as the other three
officers are concerned the big story has
been these autopsies the Floyd family
requested their own because they weren't
satisfied with the County autopsy which
they didn't think was sufficient nor do
they think the charges against officer
Chauvin are sufficient they want him
charged with first-degree murder but in
the meantime here at the scene there
have been protesters here nearly
around-the-clock this was the scene
surrounding the growing memorial for
George Floyd where he died in police
custody hundreds of protestors gathered
for a moment of unity and reflection for
several minutes they kneeled in silence
[Music]
that's Floyd's brother Terence calling
for an end to violence and looting it
was the first time any of Floyd's family
members visited the site where he died
what are you doing because that's not
gonna bring my brother back at all
yesterday the family released the
results of its independent autopsy
report which found Floyd died of
asphyxiation caused by three officers
kneeling on his back and neck cutting
off the flow of blood to his brain and
air to his lungs attorney Benjamin Crump
represents the family so I implore you
all to join his family and taking a
breath taking a breath for our country
but more importantly taking a breath for
George also yesterday the County Medical
Examiner released its updated findings
ruling that Floyd's death was a homicide
the report states Floyd died from
cardiac arrest while being restrained by
law enforcement but it also points to
hypertension and fentanyl intoxication
along with recent methamphetamine use as
contributing factors meanwhile protests
in st. Paul reached the steps of the
governor's mansion yesterday roughly two
thousand people calling for the arrest
of the three other officers involved in
Floyd's death more than a half-hour
governor Tim wall stood endless there
will be a memorial service for George
Floyd later on this week on Thursday
here in Minneapolis and then a funeral
service next week in his hometown of
Houston Anthony just the gaze thank